I'm all geared up let us hear your song
Go something like this Austin Butler has
come a long way from auditioning at 2 am
while crying in a bathrobe now he's
really singing Elvis remixes on the big
screen so yes like many of us Austin
Butler was a shy kid although he had a
year and a half to prepare for his role
as Elvis he still struggled with Stage
Fright when he first walked on set and
thought my career is on the line in this
moment what helped him actually overcome
his nerves though was the realization
that Elvis felt the exact same way as
him knowing that he had stage front
knowing that he was a shy kid all those
things really impacted and so Austin
Butler's voice was All Shook Up by this
role in order to get Elvis's distinct
Memphis accent right Austin isolated
himself from his family for three years
and worked with a voice coach Irene
Bartlett she'd focus on finding Austin's
natural Talent as well as building a
true connection with the personality of
Elvis rather than turning into an Elvis
impersonator Austin went on to say that
he felt as though he'd truly lived as
Elvis for three whole years so I'm sure
that there's just pieces of my DNA that
will always be linked in that way so how
did Austin win the role of Elvis anyway
well we can tell you one thing it's
unlike any addition Austin sent director
basilarman his first audition video but
he worried that it had gone really bad
after waking up from a nightmare one day
he thought about the fact that he and
Elvis had both lost their mothers at a
young age and he came up with a great
idea what if I sing Unchained Melody to
Mom so crying in the middle of the night
and wearing nothing but a bathrobe at
his piano Austin recorded his second
audition video and it was this that
ultimately got the attention of baz over
his many decades of Fame Elvis's look
definitely evolved a lot so to help
Austin keep up with the times we had the
most incredible Prosthetics team for
Elvis's more youthful look in the 1950s
there weren't a lot of Prosthetics that
they applied other than cheekbones and
some chin pieces that were meant to just
keep him fresher and a bit more around
faced but for the 1960s they also had to
add jaw Prosthetics just to harden his
jawline a little bit and make it more
pronounced but his most dramatic change
however doesn't come until the film
jumps to 1977 when he needed full face
chest and neck Prosthetics unlike the
other Elvis biopics this one wasn't
afraid to shake things up the soundtrack
included a number of tracks from Modern
popular artists and a lot of them offer
their own spin on Elvis's classic sound
Doja cat song Vegas for example takes
influence from Elvis's song hound dog
while Tame Impala offers us a remix of
edge of reality so like discussing the
film's mashup of Viva Las Vegas with
Britney Spears as toxic baslerman
explained that her song was chosen
because he saw a direct line between
Elvis's journey and Britney's Journey so
baz invited a group of Nashville gospel
singers on set for the film these people
aren't actors this music you can't fake
among this group was shanka ducare a
gospel singer who had been performing in
Nashville churches since she was a child
shanka thought she was a little more
than an extra when she showed up on the
set for the first day but her Talent was
so undeniable that she was offered the
role of big mama Thornton chunka said in
order to really pay tribute to her I had
to tap into myself my own
self-confidence my own voice because she
was very adamant that she only had her
voice no one could sing like her and she
sang like no one baz had to listen to
over 800 Elvis tracks to pick out the
right ones rather than choosing songs
based on personal favorites or biggest
hits Faz needed to make sure that every
Elvis song that made it into the movie
suited the story in some way and
according to him and it's really
difficult because there were so many
just what I would call Jim Austin Butler
sang a ton of the songs that Elvis
recorded during his earlier career
consider during many of the songs were
recorded on acetate making it impossible
to separate his voice from the
instruments yet some songs from the film
like Unchained Melody actually use
Elvis's original vocals as baz pointed
out you want to understand that you're
actually hearing the words of Elvis like
just a few weeks before he passes away
so Austin Butler had some Big Blue Suede
Shoes to fill before taking on the role
of the King Austin felt the need to meet
Priscilla Presley explaining that he
felt a responsibility to his family as
well as a responsibility to bring the
humanity to an icon around whom there
are so many misconceptions and although
Austin was nervous about what Priscilla
would think of the film he had nothing
to worry about well I mean he was
amazing in the film I'm just gonna come
out with it wow does Priscilla's style
ever say a lot about who she is Olivia
dejong explains that her wardrobe in the
1950s was meant to reflect the fact that
she doesn't fully know herself yet and
so as Priscilla's aging throughout the
60s we see that Elvis has a lot of say
in what she's wearing and how she's
dressing but it's actually her fashion
in the 70s where things really get
interesting so Olivia explained she's
taking a hold of her life she's Freer
meaning that every scene was kind of a
different look it was these Styles in
particular that Olivia adored wearing
these lashes and the big hair I really
hope that it comes back yeah us too so
Olivia was feeling a lot like Bambi at
the beginning of filming it kind of felt
like I was bumping around and I didn't
know how to center myself yet Olivia
found herself gaining a lot of
confidence after three years of filming
and it sounds corny but truly I felt
like a changed woman and the way she
explained it I feel way more grounded
way more centered and way more in touch
with my femininity I also have a whole
new appreciation for Aesthetics fashion
hair and makeup so who exactly was
Colonel Tom Parker baslerman admitted
that he was originally inspired to write
the script because the way he saw it
there would have been no Elvis without
Colonel Tom Parker because if Elvis
represents the soul and the new in
America the colonel represents the cell
and Tom Hanks was feeling this fresh and
unexpected approach I don't know what
Colonel Tom Parker looks like he's never
been identified as anything other than
this Mercurial or puppeteer-like
quasi-evil greedy manager that took
advantage of Elvis from the get-go and
now we get to the most important part
baslerman was obsessed with getting
Elvis's hair just right actually one of
baza's most famous quotes on set was the
hair has spoken so can we roll the
cameras referring to the moment when
Austin Butler's hair looked just right
Austin's real hair was used for any
scenes taking place during the 50s
although they did have after diet to
achieve Elvis's iconic shade of black
but for his most famous pompadour in the
70s they actually needed multiple wigs
with baz's one request being that they
keep making it higher get it higher
higher higher no celebration of Elvis
can be complete without a trip to
Graceland Austin Butler paid a visit to
the estate before filming even started
and I went in there I spent the whole
day in there by myself and it was just
the crew was able to see the blueprints
from graceland's architectural design so
that they were able to better build a
set that recreated Graceland in certain
time periods as accurately as they
possibly could you walk in through the
store and you feel like you're right in
the real life Graceland for all the
surprises that made it to the big screen
there was much more going on in Elvis
behind the scenes how successful do you
think the movie was in capturing the
music and the magic of the king don't
forget to make your thoughts heard down
below